hey this is kind of funny i was on the
dr
phil show like i didn't go anywhere but
a clip of the show was on the dr phil
show and this is really funny
it ended up being very underwhelming i'm
gonna play the clip for you
um dr phil's show producers contacted me
months ago saying david
we loved your interview about the
addictiveness of casinos
with an author who wrote about this
named natasha dao shull
and we want to use a clip for the show
we're going to feature you and natasha
can we do it sure yeah my only
requirement is
let me air the clip on my show without
filing a copyright claim i think my
audience would get a kick out of it
months of legal work and negotiations
and
paperwork i was imagining wow i mean
this
there's so much lawyer time going into
this i'm sure this is going to be like a
big
feature i think i'm on screen about four
seconds okay
don't look away because you might miss
me this is an episode
i guess about gambling problems take a
look casinos are deliberately designed
like a maze
to trap and confuse you there's no
clocks on the wall
you cannot help but be overwhelmed by
the bombardment of sounds
and light you are getting a little dose
of gambling in your brain every three
seconds
it's a gambling iv so you try to crowd
objects bring the ceiling height down
and create a sense
of sort of clutter coziness confusion
you're gonna hear ding ding ding ding
it's gonna light up
flash what if those jingles and bells
and whistles are actually
there to encourage you to make risky
decisions you go into that trance that
zone that box
nobody can touch you you have escaped
from reality no one can ask you for
anything
so that that's it those four seconds
pretty underwhelming so to me the shock
is the amount of
paperwork for a few seconds of me on dr
phil
it must be a lawyer's dream to be
clearing rights for these shows if they
spent
two months three months of legal work to
get four seconds of me
i can't even imagine what's going on
with you know copyrighted music
or whatever else so that was me on dr
phil
um i i don't know what else to say maybe
maybe it's interesting
in some way but uh the back story is
lots and lots of legal negotiations to
make it happen